and now an art exhibition just a short
drive away from the Pro Football Hall of
Fame in Canton Ohio looks at the sports
popularity throughout its history Dana
Jacobson got a look in a small studio in
Brooklyn
Sean Leonardo creates contemporary art
that examines big issues like identity
and masculinity subjects he became
familiar with as a football player at
Bowdoin College in Maine how different
of an artist do you think you'd be
without football incredibly Leonardo
produced this piece of performance art
called bull in the ring which first
appeared at the Los Angeles County
Museum of Art in 2008 as not an
experience I would ever forget and not
in a positive way know the drill which
has been banned for the most part or
amended has a single player defending
himself from teammates who are charging
from all directions there's no accident
that all the players are wearing not
only my number they're all also wearing
visors this was all because in my mind
this memory exists as a nightmare
Leonardo says he's questioning macho
rituals that men experience as rites of
passage it's pervasive in every sport
and I think it's echoed in the military
in politics and family in the workplace
we're at once supposed to be a team
player at the same time survive exhibit
superiority
Leonardo's video is currently on display
at the Canton Museum of Art in Ohio part
of the exhibition scrimmage max Barton
is the museum's executive director who
knew that football could make you think
about so many different things
absolutely this is not football art this
is the art of football that is teaching
you about where our country came from
scrimmage brings 78 works together from
150 years of American art this is Andy
Warhol and this is from the mid 70s with
his series called the athletes items
range from Polaroids and a screen print
of OJ Simpson we don't think of OJ as
even being a part of the game of
football anymore because of what
that celebrity has become to a painting
by the iconic American artist Norman
Rockwell do young boys today dream of
growing up to being the football star
the football hero which the title this
piece is a little boy has a lot of
heroes from the 1961 Rockwell so these
are the series of photos that started
the scrimmage exhibition two photographs
of today's young players and this is
really a study of what do players look
like before they go on the field before
they become part of the team is he that
the nerd is he the captain of the team
the exhibition which was originally
curated by staff at Colorado State and
the University of Oregon tackles eight
different themes like race class and
ethnicity and violence this piece which
is called the onslaught it gives you an
idea about the the roughness the
brutality of the game and what goes on
inside the football scrum the section
includes fumble in the line by Ernie
Barnes so he has an interesting story
and that he was both artist and football
player her name was played for five
seasons went to college on a football
scholarship to study art he was known by
his teammates in the NFL as big
Rembrandt was the name that he was
called on the sidelines around twenty of
the pieces are on loan from the personal
collection of Michael or yard okay so
these are pieces by Frederick Remington
in Harper's Weekly like this wood
engraved collage from 1888 and so the
background here is actually you know
multiple lines everything had to be hand
art this is art or yard played college
football at Notre Dame and four seasons
in the NFL with the Kansas City Chiefs
he would go on to become a professor of
English at Oregon State University as
football became popular or was beginning
and it was beginning at elite
universities at Harvard Yale and
Princeton and you know Harper's Weekly
was interested in that audience they
began representing the game over the
years or yard began amassing a treasure
trove of the earliest depictions of the
game you know most of this is through
ebay and
eBay gives you access to everybody's
attic right Ori art has published six
books on the game the most recent the
art of football which looks at the
period from 1870 to 1920 gender was
central to football from the very
beginning because it was just
overwhelmingly and obviously male
masculine and and football's initial
appeal came from that fact that my
anxiety and the society that that
Americans were getting soft by working
in factories now instead of on farms and
women were essential to to the game
because their presence sort of validated
it you know football is is not sheer
brutality
you know if women can enjoy it race has
always been a part of this race has
always been a part of it black colleges
started playing football in the 1890s
just like everybody else in the country
but football in the south was a wholly
segregated I played in college against
segregated teams or yard points out that
a number of former African American
players in the early twentieth century
like Paul Robeson and William Henry
Lewis would become influential activists
and politicians decades later a new
generation of football players are also
expressing themselves through activism
and maybe even art is it safe to say
that contact Roenick taking a knee in
some ways is performance art I think
it's very much so and I think what one
one thing that I'm attempting to argue
is that our life on the field very much
mirrors our experience and existence
outside of the field and we all at some
point feel a need to make that gesture
for CBS this morning Saturday Dana
Jacobson Canton Ohio it looks like a
fascinating exhibit yeah especially now
that football is really at the front
lines of cultural debate good timing